c'est une semaine d'angoise de fièvre de
critiques assassines ou de louanges qui
vient de commencer à paris la semaine où
les magiciens de la haute couture
française dévoile leurs créations pour
la saison 83 la mode cette année est au
rétro au voyage dans le temps au mini
est au parfum 1900 notre père maison
france roche daniel mailhot et patrice
du tertre nous dévoile l'essentiel la
tour eiffel se refait une beauté elle
maigrit de milton émet des voilettes sur
son lifting de son premier étage nous
allons remonter de deux siècles dans le
temps et dans ses souvenirs avec
d'autres demoiselles à la mode de toutes
les mains dans la mode d'aujourd'hui est
à la mode et c'est justement cette
rousse de louis féraud couverte d'iris
guy laroche remonte plus loin il est
allé évoqué une merveilleuse directoire
à qui il a donné des manches cormeilles
c'est un grisette 1860 que l'envoi veut
nous transformer cet été en route pour
deauville années folles taille basse
jupe tube nina ricci même taille basse
genre boeuf sur le toit lapidus est
toujours taillé base pour garder une
partie troisième république louis féraud
prenons le virage on arrive à 35,40
capeline garbo canotiers chevalier
cinéma noir et blanc jean louis ferrer
se souvient des smokings de marlène
toujours couleurs de dominos avec des
flous qui cache ses débuts astier qui
révèle anna est mauvais chanel le bijou
arrogant le demi d'oeil discret
d'ailleurs pour fan de valentino de
serge lepage enfin dans la salle fl
comme au casino de paris
une robe de bal main pour mistinguett on
enchaîne sur les stars 1950 pour ita
gildard crêpes blanc et sequins noirs de
la roche venait pour s habiller lena
horne chantant la vie en strass l'un
pastel et python torrent a eu la
nostalgie d'une certaine grace kelly
tasséré jupes larges souvenir de kim
novak pour carven
pour sylvain riss la roma you can't hide
nina ricci et pour audrey hepburn
labasque vacances romaines de garde
petit saut vers 60 le blouson noir de
brando et devon doré chez perse book et
le temps d'enfourcher notre moto foutait
de diamant on atterrit sur les mini de
la mini mini mini de satin et de spock
réduite à sa plus simple expression
géométriques et bicolore courage
retrouve ses débuts à la fois enfantine
arts le kin espagnol lanvin
et pour paco rabanne un festival de cuir
tendre clouté d'argent
pour une cascade très courte de petits
soleils pour jouer les boules à tango
enfin voici des fleurs de tous les temps
pour tout l'été fleur de pommier sur des
paniers que le courage l'homme pompadour
balmain lui aussi sculpte des pétales
enroulée en jupe pour lapidus une rose
blanche ébouriffés avec un coeur
et pour cardin tout une tonnelle
pas tous mais des roses sur une tige
il propose pour le soir une gerbe
d'anniversaire quant à lepage vous
laisse avec son livre noir qui attend
des nuits blanches celles du printemps